how much do physicists think about
possibility well they think about it in
terms of probability
more often but probability just
describes
and again this is a place where I might
be out of my depth and need to talk to
somebody to to debunk this but the um do
therapy with a physicist yeah
um but probability it seems just
describes a pattern of actuality that
we've observed
right I mean we have there are certain
things we observe
and those are the actual things that
have happened
and we have this additional story about
probability I mean is it we have the
frequency with which things happen have
happened in the past
um
you know I can flip a Fair coin and know
I know in the abstract that I have a
belief that in the limit that those
flips you know those tosses should
Converge on 50 heads and 50 Tails I know
I have a story as to why it's not going
to be exactly 50 within any
arbitrary time frame
um
but in reality all we ever have are the
observed tosses
right and then we have an additional
story that oh it came up heads but it
could have come up tails
why do we think that
about that last toss
what and and what are we claiming is
true
about the physics of things
if we say it could have been otherwise I
think we're claiming that probability is
true
that that just it allows us to
have a nice model about the world it
gives us hope about the world yeah it
seems that possibility has to be
somewhere to be effective it's a little
it's a little bit like what's what's
happening with the laws there's
something metaphysically interesting
about the laws of nature too because the
laws of nature so the laws of nature
impose their their work on the world
right we see their evidence
but they're not reducible to any
specific set of instances right so
there's some structure there
but the structure isn't
just a matter of the actual things with
the actual billiard balls that are
banging into each other
all of that actuality can be explained
by what actual things are actually doing
but then we have this notion that in
addition to that
we have the laws of nature that are
making they're explaining this act but
but how are the laws of nature an
additional thing
in addition to just the actual things
that are actually effect costly and if
they're if they are an additional thing
in how are they effective if not they're
not among the actual things that are
just actually banging around yeah and so
to some degree for that possible
possibly has to be hiding somewhere for
the laws on nature to be possible
for anything to be possible it has to be
it has to have a closet somewhere I'm
sure it's just where all the possibility
goes it has to be attached to something
so you don't think many worlds is that
yeah because Mayweather still exists
well because we're in this strand of
that Multiverse yeah right so it's still
still you have just a local instance of
what is actual yeah and then if it
proliferates elsewhere where you can't
be affected by it maybe you can't really
connect with the other yeah yeah and so
many worlds is just a statement of
basically everything that can happen
happens somewhere
right that's yeah you know and that's I
mean maybe that's not an entirely kosher
formulation of it but it it seems pretty
close so so but there's whatever happens
right in fact there's you know
relativistically there's a
there's a you know the the Einstein's
original notion of a block universe
seems to suggest this and I it's been a
while since I've been in a conversation
with a physicist where I've gotten a
chance to ask about the standing of this
concept in physics currently I don't
hear it discuss much but the idea of a
block universe is that you know the
space-time
exists as a totality in our sense that
we are traveling
through space-time
where there's a real difference between
the past and the future
that that's an illusion of just our you
know
you know weird the weird the weird slice
we're taking of of this larger object
but on some level
it's like you know you're reading a
novel The last page of the novel exists
just as much as the first page when
you're in the middle of it and they're
just
you know if that's if we're living in
anything like that then there's no such
thing as
possibility I I would it would seem this
just
what is actual so
as a matter of our experience moment to
moment
I think it's totally compatible with
that being true that there is only what
is actual and
that sounds to the the naive ear that
sounds like it would be depressing and
disempowering and confining but it's
anything but it's actually it's a
circumstance of pure Discovery like you
have no idea what's going to happen next
right you don't know who you're going to
be tomorrow you're only by tendency
seeming to resemble yourself from
yesterday and there's there's way more
freedom in all of that than than it
seems true to many people and
yet
the basic Insight is that you're not
you're not in the the real freedom is is
the recognition that you're not in
control of anything everything is just
happening including your thoughts and
intentions and moves so life is a is a
process of continuous Discovery you're
part of the universe yeah you are you
are just this I mean it's
it's the miracle that the the universe
is illuminated to itself as itself where
you sit and you're and you're
continually discovering
what your life is
and then you're you have this layer at
which you're telling yourself a story
that you already know what your life is
and you know exactly you know who you
should be and what's you know what's
about to happen or you're struggling to
form a confident opinion about all of
that and yet there is this this
fundamental mystery to everything even
the most familiar experience
we're all NPCs in in the most marvelous
video game
maybe although my my game my sense of
gaming is does not run as deep as to
know what I'm committing to there's a
non it's a non-plane character you're
more yeah oh wow yes you're more you're
more of a Mario Kart guy yeah yeah I
went back I was an original video gamer
but it's been a long time since I I mean
I was I was there for pong I remember
when I saw the first pong in a
restaurant in uh
I think it was like Benihana's or
something they had a pong and a table
and that was it amazing it was an
amazing moment when he was you Sam
harrisman I lived from pong
to the invention and deployment of a
super intelligent system yeah well that
that happened fast if it happens anytime
in my lifetime from from pong to AGI